earlier today
i uh i visited a restaurant
here in town i said
i'm going to mispronounce it while
and which is a pilot program for
restaurant revitalization fund
and an important piece of the american
rescue plan
one of my goals in the american rescue
plan is to make sure
that we get this law's benefits quickly
and directly to the american people
so uh before i say a bit more about what
we're doing to support our nation's
restaurants
let me provide an update on what is
happening through the american rescue
plan
right now as i speak
first is providing checks and pockets
and shots and arms
more than 163 million rescue payments
have already gone out
these are checks direct payments of up
to fourteen hundred dollars
that for a typical family of four making
about a hundred
ten thousand dollars means a five
thousand six hundred dollar
check yoga by the time all the money is
distributed
more than 85 percent of american
households will receive the check
the rescue plan is also funding vaccine
administration and distribution
it's a big reason why we're able to
administer over 220 million shots in my
first hundred days
a pace unmatched by any other nation in
the world
or in prior mass vaccinations in all of
american history
you know it's helps schools reopen
safely it's helping child care centers
stay in business
it's helping families pay for child care
rescue plan is delivering food and
nutrition assistance to millions of
americans facing hunger
and hunger is already sharply down in
the united states
it's also providing rental assistance to
keep people from being evicted from
their homes
it's making health care more affordable
it's cutting
child poverty in this country in half
the list goes on
and the message is clear help is here
and the bottom line is this the american
rescue plan
is working america is getting vaccinated
job creation is soaring the economy is
growing
and our country is on the move again but
some of the parts of the
of our economy need special help at the
top of that list is our nation's
restaurants
when culvert 19 pandemic struck our
nation's restaurants were
some of the first hit and the worst hit
in 2020 more than 2
32 million 2.3 million
restaurants jobs disappeared 2.3 million
restaurant jobs disappeared
restaurants are more than a major driver
economy
they're woven in the fabric of our
communities
and so for many families restaurants are
the gateway to opportunity
a key part of the american story there
are families of all races all
ethnic backgrounds all nationalities in
this country who have built their
american dream around a family
a family-owned restaurant and for more
workers their own story of economic
progress
starts in a restaurant in the restaurant
i just visited
and rogelio martinez
who immigrated to this country 17 years
ago
started working as a meatpacker now he's
the restaurant's lead butcher
and one of its owners for nearly one in
three americans
arrested is hard to believe but from one
in three americans
a restaurant provided their first child
more than half of all americans
have worked at a restaurant at some
point in their lives
before the pandemic restaurants and bars
employed 12
12 of all the workers in our country
this is an industry
that provided more opportunity for
minority managers than any other
industry in america
this is an industry where the staff
feels like family and often is family
when the pandemic kid restaurant owners
and operators were resilient creative
and generous
almost overnight restaurants put in
place safety measures to protect their
employees
and to protect us they stepped up to
feed our frontline workers
they changed their menus they
transitioned to take out a delivery
so they could be serving people who
depended on them
but when but even with the changes
many had to furlough or lay off workers
or close
entirely the restaurant i visited today
went from 55 employees to just seven
before it started to bounce back now as
we vaccinate americans
customers are coming back the vaccinate
our vaccination progress and our
economic recovery
is going hand in hand as that happens we
want to make sure that our restaurants
bars and other dining establishments can
staff
back up and they can come back as well
right now only about a quarter of the
restaurant owners expect to return to
normal operations in the next six months
we can do much better than that with the
american rescue plan
the restaurant revitalization fund
that's what it's called revitalization
fund
will provide direct relief to
restaurants
and to hard-hit food establishments bars
bakeries
food stands food trucks and caterers
businesses that get grants can use it to
cover payroll
rent utilities supplies
everything they need to start to stay
open and too real
we are we're opening the doors of this
program
for so that restaurants all over the
country can open their doors again
we started accepting that we started
accepting applications on monday
today's wednesday we made it quick and
easy to apply
within the first two days there were 186
200 applications from all 50 states for
help that's a staggering number
97 97
600 of those applications came from
businesses owned by women
veterans and socio-economically
disadvantaged individuals
now the applications they have all have
been processed
but right now it looks like we'll be
able to provide help to about 100
000 restaurants and other eligible
businesses
we passed the american recipe plan we
did that some people said it wasn't
needed
this response proves them wrong it's
badly needed
about a year ago when the first round of
the paycheck protection program
opened up a lot of the smallest firms
saw the doors
shut in their face the law was written
so that
as as we process these applications a
new one
we focus first on those who are left
behind
by the other relief programs and to make
sure
the relief is distributed fairly we also
set aside funds
for the smallest restaurants bars food
trucks and many family-owned restaurants
that haven't gotten any help to date and
they need it
that way they don't have to compete
above their weight class
for these grants sixty-one thousand
sorry for all the numbers but they're
important
sixty-one 700 applications have come
come from the smaller bars and
restaurants already
i want to thank the small business
administrator isabel guzman
for the work that she and her team are
doing to make sure
we get help quickly and fairly to the
businesses that need it the most
as i said i've spoken to dozens of
restaurants owners about the challenges
they face
but i've also received letters from
people who want to tell me about the
restaurant owners in their communities
i received one letter from a man who
asked me to look out for a pair of local
restaurant owners
we described as quote the hardest
working people i've ever met end quote
another letter was from a woman wanted
to tell me about how important
the couple that ran the restaurant town
there
was she said they are quote the strong
consistent foundation of our community
and the quote whether it's our economy
or our sense of community
we're relying on restaurants to play a
big role in our recovery
we want our economy to recover in a way
that deals everyone in
that our restaurants need a seat at the
table no pun intended
that's what we're giving them that's
what this program is about
a seat at the table this is another
example of how we're putting the
american rescue plan to work quickly and
effectively
and showing the american people that
their government can deliver
can deliver for them again and do
without waste
that we can vaccinate this nation we can
get our kids safely back in school
that we can get our economy back on
track by helping
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses reopen and
stay open and we can give the people
this nation
a fighting chance again that's what this
is all about
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops thank you
you're going to be a waiver of the year
at the wto are you going to back that is
the u.s government
president biden you said earlier you
don't understand republicans
listen what does it say about them if
they asked liz cheney from leadership
for telling the truth about the election
it seems as though the republican party
is trying to identify what it stands for
and they're in the midst of a
significant uh sort of revolution
going on in the republican party um
i've been a democrat for a long time
we've gone through periods we've had
internal fights and disagreements i
don't ever remember any
like this and so
as one of you said and i'm not
embarrassed by identifying them
if one of you said on national
television last night
we badly need a republican party
we need a two-party system it's not
healthy never one party system
and i think the republicans are
further away from trying to figure out
who they are and what they stand for
than i thought they would be at this
point sir mitch mcconnell said that he
is 100
focused on stopping this administration
you've spoken about your relationship
with him in the past
do you still think he can work with him
when he says things like that
look um he said that
in my last administration barack he was
going to stop everything
and i was able to get a lot done with
him
again
look
everything i'm proposing
that be done to generate economic growth
employment and
put us in a position where we can
out-compete
any other country in the world with
research and development
and moving ahead i pay for
we talk about i lovely talk about how
this is going to cost so much money i'm
not paying for it
the bottom line is this
my republican friends
had no problem voting to pass a tax
proposal
that expires in 2025
that cost two trillion dollars
none of it paid for increased the
deficit by
two trillion dollars
gave the overwhelming percentage of
those tax breaks
to people who didn't need it the top one
tenth of one percent
it didn't need it and
it was argued that what it would do is
generate this great economic
surge and growth it would increase
productivity
it would pay for itself it would
generate
a sense of growth in america we hadn't
seen
ever before well everyone from the
heritage foundation on it's pointed out
i hadn't done that
hadn't done that now i come along
and the proposals that i'm suggesting
are tried and true things like when you
rebuild bridges
things get better when you rebuild
highways
and you don't have to uh you know
you airports ports it all matters
it increases productivity
and the programs that relate to
people are programs that
are the things that also generate
economic growth
and i view them as for example
tax cuts for middle class upper middle
class middle class and working class
people
and so you eliminate
a few of the just have the super wealthy
begin to pay their fair share
for example you have you know you have
i think it's 35 or 30 corporations
didn't pay a single solitary penny last
year and the fortune 500 companies
they made 400 billion dollars they paid
no taxes
how could that make any sense
especially since these corporations and
i come from a corporate capital of the
world
more corporations are incorporated in my
state than all the rest of the country
combined
if you notice corporations aren't
investing any money in research and
development
somewhere what's most of it going to do
buying back their own stock
stock dividends which makes sense
leaving by some studies less than 10
for research development pay raises etc
used to be that uh not too long ago
for example during the bush
administration
the tax rate for the very wealthy making
well over millions of dollars
was 39.6
it's now 37 just raised it back to what
it was before
it raises enough money from that savings
to put every
single person in community college who
wants to go
and what's going to grow america more
what's going to help you and your
security more
the super wealthy having
to pay three
point almost yeah 3.9
less tax or have an
entire generation of americans
having associate degrees that's why all
the economists even a wall streeter
pointed out
guess what it grows the economy
benefits everybody hurts nobody
but now it's talked to the northeast
journal i talk about the welfare program
it's about growth
and so you know the idea that
it's just amazing i mean
corporate taxes
they were 36 percent
our administration last administration
said we should lower it
we suggested to be lower to 28
well it's got lower to 20 or 21
show me something that's benefited
what's happened
show me where the growth is what's it
being invested in
yes on the corporate tax rate have you
talked to ceos about that um
and have you yes have you are you open
to say 25
i'm open to compromising yes it doesn't
have to be exactly what i say but to
suggest that
which some of the folks are suggesting
and i'm going to meet with republicans
next week when they come back
and seriously be with them i'm willing
to compromise
but i'm not willing to not pay for what
we're talking about
i'm not willing to deficit spend
they already have us 2 trillion in the
hole
so and by the way you saw
you know the uh the last
five leaders of fed com coming out and
saying what they say
they said biden's plan is going to grow
the economy
that moody's talking about increasing up
to i don't know what the most recent one
is 16 million new jobs
it's about growth not stunting growth
like i said not too long ago i guess was
back in the
in the 2000 range there about home in
the exact year i'll get
have my staff come back to the exact
date
the average ceo of the fortune 500
companies made like 36 times what the
average employee of that corporation
made
it's over 450 times how much now
as my mother would say who died and left
them boss
no seriously what rationale
tell me what benefit
flows to that we're not going to deprive
these executives their
second or third home travel privately by
jet
that's not going to affect your standard
living at all not a little tiny bit
but i can affect the standard of living
that people i grew up with
if they have a job i can expect to
make sure the standard of liberty the
people i grew up with
if they have child care can afford it so
20 million
women can be back in the workforce
this is just not makes no sense to me
but it's gonna i'm gonna have to be able
to explain this
and i'm gonna keep banging at it i think
i'm not being solicitous so i'm not
trying to ruin your reputation i think
most of you understand what i'm saying
whether you agree with me or not i think
you understand what i'm saying it's fair
to say this is about
making the average multi-millionaire
pay just a fair share it's not going to
affect their standard living
a little bit thank you all very much
the interest rate